alex zulle madame monsieur bonsoir mais
tout de suite bien évidemment le point
sur l'évolution de plus en plus
dramatique en bosnie face à la passivité
de la communauté internationale les
serbes de bosnie semble bien décidé à
pousser leur avantage ils ont lancé un
ultimatum aux autorités des enclaves
musulmanes 2 et pie 2 go raj et nous y
reviendrons dans un instant après la
chute de cerenis ça on a de plus en plus
d'inquiétudes sur le sort d'un certain
nombre de prisonniers musulmans alors qu
environ 1 30 mille réfugiés musulmans
sont massés à tuzla où les responsables
de l'onu parle de désastre humanitaire
tout de suite le point avec isabelle
bechler la lutte pour la vie au père de
l'europe se battre pour umich de pain ou
quelques tomates
nous ne sommes qu'à deux heures d'avion
de paris voici la première solidarité
des boulangers bassignac pour les vingt
mille trente mille civils peut-être que
les serbes ont forcé or de srebrenica
depuis trois jours il musulmans qu'il
croyait vivre dans une enclave protégé
par les casques bleus des nations unies
trente mille qui ont tout laissé
derrière les baluchons des réfugiés
rwandais font figure de luxe à côté de
ce dénuement de la population de
srebrenica et il fait si chaud et
l'ombre est si rare un abri et on
pourrait éviter la déshydratation des
enfants mais comment soigner les malaise
qu'ont les humanitaires ne sont pas
encore arrivées de trop rares camions
citernes distribuer de l'eau à peine
potable et l'hygiène terrible de ce coin
improvisé laisse présager une épidémie
de dysenterie les plus chanceux des
exilés de srebrenica ceux qui ont de la
famille à tuzla essaie de rejoindre la
ville
des camionnettes à bétail sont une
navettes incessantes mais qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait de mon frère les serbes
l'ont emmené il avait seulement 17 ans
ou est-ce qu'il est passé rendez le mois
les femmes sont effectivement la
majorité des adultes
il y à 2 % d'hommes seulement et 70 %
d'enfants voilà le résultat de cette
épuration ethnique pratiquée par les
serbes dans la population de srebrenica
sous le regard impuissant des casques
bleus avec la complicité des casques
bleus 10 et femmes qui invective ses
soldats de la provocation
fils de [ __ ] toi ton fils ne mourra
jamais moi les deux miens sont en train
de crever là bas